hello my name is Toby and I do not shoot
first that is my rule you may be shocked
to see me here playing fortnight
this is not very on brand but don't
worry because I will talk about some
physics while we're here the physics
comes later but first some context John
Green a person who I respect greatly and
have met once has a series on YouTube
where he plays for tonight as a pacifist
hiding in bushes and only shooting in
self-defense I have thoroughly enjoyed
John's videos but he is yet to succeed
at his task of winning the game today as
you may tell from the title I succeeded
in the pacifist style this is the story
of how I said no to violence winning a
solo victory with zero kills zero
building and zero shots fired I learned
everything I know about the game from
John's videos which isn't much to be
honest
I barely know how to control the
character and you can see just how
gracefully I'm falling down to land the
zero build humble brag in the title
comes from the fact that I don't
actually know how to build the footage
you are watching is what I have managed
to scrape out of the autosave to replay
feature the second half of this video
will have the map display showing their
number of surviving participants but for
this first half of the replay it was
exported without the map and since this
was played a little while ago the file
became corrupted due to updates before I
could export a new version I'm not very
good at the camera angles here I don't
know how to operate them but my tactic
is to find somewhere to hide I went for
this hill so I could have a vantage
point it was nice and high it's best to
hide where you can see others but they
cannot see you I've picked up the small
gun to use purely in self defense I will
not fire this gun unless I am being shot
at by another individual if you are
unfamiliar with the game a company
called
epic games has forced a hundred people
to live inside of a party bus that they
then have to jump out of seeking refuge
on an island where they fight each other
to the death the last one standing is
able to go free with their life it is a
horrible and sad situation and there is
a great deal of desperation born out of
the desperate situation in which
participants find themselves in this
game a terrible storm surrounds the
island and over time the habitable part
of the island gets smaller and smaller
this forces individuals to get closer to
each other and means that it is unlikely
I'll be able to hide on this hill for
too long I will run from the storm when
I see it approaching I think that people
here have been forced to act inhumanely
by a culture which supports such actions
one pacifist alone is likely to be
killed instantly when encountered even
if they do come in peace as in such a
tense environment as this every movement
is perceived as a threat
the only real hope that a pacifist can
have here is that they encounter other
pacifists in the game maybe I will find
myself in the final moments face to face
with John Green himself and the two of
us can emerge from our shrubs and unite
in a dance watching the storm claim us
both in an act of defiance
that's the philosophical aspect of it
I'm also just really scared of conflict
just a heads up that I do spend a
reasonable amount of time sitting on
this hill I'll put a time stamp to when
it gets a bit more exciting but for now
grab a cup of tea or whatever and sit
back and I'll tell you some stories
I can hear menacing sounds and the
distance of other people exploding each
other it sounded like but I'm going to
try and put that out of my mind for now
and just stay calm we here on this hill
fortnight is such a quintessential part
of YouTube culture at the moment as you
may have seen in the highly enjoyable
and well liked YouTube rewind for 2018
my channel recently passed a hundred
thousand subscribers and I wanted to do
a little something different to
celebrate some people jokingly suggested
that it's time for me to end my real
youtube stripes and upload a fortnight
video and here we are
I assure you though that this is just a
little fun celebration of sorts and you
shouldn't expect any more fortnight
videos on my channel I had a couple of
footsteps there I hope someone's not
coming to my hiding spot because I
honestly don't have a plan B at this
stage so while we are waiting for the
others to kill each other let's talk
about an intersection of physics and
pacifism this is a physics channel after
all you will probably know about the
number of famous physicists involved in
the Manhattan Project based in the u.s.
to create the first nuclear weapons
Robert Oppenheimer
Richard Fineman Enrico Fermi were some
of the big name physicists involved
Einstein a person who was widely
regarded as a pacifist may have also
been involved in the conception of the
project in 1939 scientists came to know
about uranium fission the process which
would be used in atomic bombs there were
some great concerns that German
scientists would use it to develop
nuclear weapons and so physicist Leo
Szilard worked with Einstein to write a
letter to US President Franklin
Roosevelt which Einstein signed urging
the u.s. to be the first to develop such
a weapon by 1942 this push had become
the Manhattan Project by late 1945 the
u.s. used nuclear bombs
the Japanese cities of Hiroshima and
Nagasaki with devastating loss of life
apparently Einstein later expressed
regret about his letter Einstein had
originally justified his decision
because of the greater danger that Nazi
Germany would develop the bomb first in
1947 Einstein said had I known that the
Germans would not succeed in developing
an atomic bomb I would have done nothing
the saw regret makes sense because
Einstein was a pacifist at heart and
believed that was stood in the way of
human progress his version of pacifism
was one of preparedness he believed that
he had no alternative but to act to
encourage nations to be prepared against
the perceived threats posed to them
Einstein himself wrote this about his
position I did not say that
I was an absolute pacifist but rather
that I had always been a convinced
pacifist while I am a convinced pacifist
there are circumstances in which I
believe the use of force is appropriate
namely in the face of an enemy
unconditionally bent on destroying me
and my people
I am a dedicated but not an absolute
pacifist this means that I am opposed to
the use of force under any circumstances
except when confronted by an enemy who
pursues the destruction of life as an
end in itself
I suppose this is my view of pessimism
whilst playing for night I will not seek
out conflict even if I were to see an
easy target from up here on my perch but
I do hold this gun in an act of
preparedness whether I am skilled enough
to fire it is another question entirely
I'm probably not and this makes hiding
also a smart decision for my own
survival ideally I would be hiding in a
bush or behind a tree or something but
as long as I stay reasonably still I'm
not too worried there wasn't a
convenient enough bush up here where I
wanted to hide human eyes
actually kind of bad at seeing
stationary objects while scanning the
field human eyes are really good at
detecting movement though the ability to
detect movement is key for many animals
allowing them to detect the presence of
predators when I look out across the
Fortnight landscape the only way I see
other characters is through their
movements which stand out against the
static background so I'm trying to stay
still or pivot slowly to reduce the
chance of being seen it is kind of like
hiding in plain sight in a way with each
second that passes I get closer to my
death the last time I played four at
night I also tried to hide out on this
very hill but died by falling off the
side and suffering a great fall I
couldn't work out how to like open my
umbrella thing to soften the fall so I
could easily die like that again in the
exact same way or I could make it a
little longer this time whether my death
occurs in the game though or afterwards
the fact is I have limited time both
options highlight the absurdity of
conflict humans do love to fight the
game meets a need to squash others and
emerge victorious I am NOT unaware of
this aspect of human nature and it is
good to realize it to quote Carl Sagan
it is far better to grasp the universe
as it is than to persist in delusion
however satisfying and reassuring Sagan
had many great quotes he also said that
extinction is the rule survival is the
exception many species over the course
of history have gone extinct and many
more will do so extinction can happen
naturally as the world changes but it
has also been sped up in recent times by
human factors such as urbanization
and habitat loss it seems though that
the rule for any species is indeed to
eventually become extinct in a few
billion years the Sun will use at the
last of its hydrogen fuel and expend 250
times its current size there is no
guarantee that even the most resilient
species on earth could survive this and
for humans to continue to survive
broadly speaking we would have to take
action to become the exception maybe it
is inhabiting other faraway worlds and
developing a spacefaring species that's
the grand scale but look around at the
situation I find myself in and you will
see this on the local scale a hundred
people were dropped on this island 99 of
them will become extinct if you will and
one will survive to become that
exception you need to have something
special about you or a lot of luck I did
have a little luck on my side and the
fact that this hiding perch of mine was
inside the safe zone and not in the
storm for a good little while also
nobody has yet run directly past and
seen me which means I can just sit here
you can see the storm out in the
distance getting closer it's purple and
glowing and it has some elements that
remind me of what is often portrayed in
movies as a geomagnetic or a solar storm
I don't know the exact origins of the
fortnight storm but maybe it does have a
component of magnetic activity you might
have seen earlier there were a lot of
like bright purple streaks and the storm
so maybe that is some charged particles
like electrons or protons that have made
their way from the Sun ejected in a
solar storm and made their way into the
upper atmosphere of Earth where they may
interact with the atmospheric particles
through excitation ionization and caused
some you know colorful displays and
patterns I guess I won't know what
causes it but it was a pretty sight to
look at before my impending
doom here's the part where the footage
was able to be exported with the map and
you can see how many people are left 13
in fact I can see someone over there in
the distance building so that's a little
stressful there they are flying off
their structure down into the hills
I'm currently outside the safe zone and
the storm is going to be shrinking soon
so I need to move and I need to get
somewhere safe this is how I died last
time jumping off this ledge so I'm kind
of hoping it goes better this time I
need to deploy a parasail at some point
up yep good enough not the most graceful
I must say in fact this whole section
here I'm kind of running around like a
headless Chuck I don't know which way to
go I'm going the wrong way
oh I'm pretty certain I'm gonna die
right about now because I'm extremely
close to the storm and there's a hill on
the other side of me so I'm stuck
between a rock and a and approaching
storm
I was very pessimistic during this part
right here during this run with each
second that passes I'm kind of amazed
that I'm still alive somehow and I'm
just running randomly around the
mountain looking for a nice bush to hide
in and take some shelter not only from
the storm but from the people who can
probably see me running and will come
and shoot me I'm now inside the safe
zone so then I go and make one of the
worst decisions ever which is to run
into this bush which is actually outside
the safe zone but I didn't realize at
the time and I'm sitting in here just
feeling incredibly stressed my Bloods
rushing with their dren illan and you
know I'm thinking okay I might be safe a
little bit I'll just just sit here for
the time being get nice and comfortable
in this bush so no one can see my
ponytails to hang out and then this
happens it's not an at all I'm losing
health and now I'm long I don't know
what to do
I'm that was my best spot so I'm gonna
have to run and find another bush it's
kind of a miracle no one's seen me
flailing about like this so far I feel
like this this is just luck
no one else was here building because
like I said I didn't have any plan B's
this looks like a good bush retreat here
for a bit but it's still not in the next
safe zone which you can see on the map
is the white circle top eight that I
think it's only eight people left
including myself that's pretty good for
someone who's done basically nothing so
far in here gunshots in the distance if
you actually see people over there
building and fighting I'll just be a
bush camper this is a technique I
learned from John Green he seems to be
an expert bush camper and I think that's
a pretty good tactic to be honest I know
I'm going to need to run soon we've got
15 seconds until the storm starts moving
again I'm going to need to run towards
that white circle to be safe but I think
I'll take my time I feel like my biggest
threat at this point is someone seeing
me running
so all those footsteps I better go I
don't know what I'm doing
he has a nice book also not in the safe
zone can't see anyone else though coast
seems clear
my small inkling of hope was that Bush
over there as long as I can get there
that anyone seeing me it's fine Oh God
there was someone shooting at me I this
was a very tense moment did did someone
shoot at me from up here I'm trying to
see them why are they still not shooting
at me today did they lose sight of me I
mean it's kind of obvious I went in this
bush what did they get shot by someone
else
who knows I guess it's a pure miracle
that they didn't keep shooting because
that's probably my number one chance of
death right there somehow had survived
just looking around to see where the
others are they're up there I guess I
have to assume everyone I see is in the
exact same situation as me right
I can't assume that they're trying to
kill me I can't oh god I can only assume
that they're part of the corrupt power
system trying to turn us against each
other to turn us into animals and and I
have to assume that like me they're
they're just trying to survive and a
horrible situation in which they found
themselves I don't like those noises but
somehow I'm in the top three Oh God
feel like one of them won't fascinators
then so there's two people and me left
in this game as long as those two kill
each other
I'm good I'm good I understand this push
yes remember assume he's just like me
he's just frolicking in the park did
something gonna happen up there I feel
but as long as I stay here in till the
last minute I can fall god I guess their
priorities are each other and then
they'll come after me oh no I'm exposed
I'm completely I've got nowhere to hide
except over here they're distracted it's
good they're distracted I don't even
want to look I'm just gonna keep my head
down they won't see me if I do that and
I don't want to see them I don't want to
know what's going on I'm just gonna sit
here and hope for the best
okay I don't even know what I'm hoping
for I'm just hoping for the best and I'm
just looking at the grass and trying to
stay calm I'm very stressed
- oh my god and this was the moment it
happened this is my victory royale I
don't know what that gunshots I don't
know if I accidentally shot myself I
shot the bush after my victory I was so
excited right now I'm actually running
upstairs to tell my brother what
happened
this is his account by the way so don't
add this account thinking that it's
going to be me it's gonna be him looks
like the storm does eventually cover me
so even you know if you win by the rules
that if it came to set out and you
actually you know do what they wanted
you to do you're still gonna end up in
the storm so I don't really see any good
way out of this I did manage to get some
footage through the replay of in
hindsight what happened to those other
two players and so we can have a look at
that now it's on a fast-forward so here
was me running there was them distracted
by each other building building and
something I don't know how to do that
was pretty skilled to be honest pretty
menacing there's a lot going on some
shots one gets shot and then the other
just dies in the storm somehow so they
must have had such low health that even
a little bit of time in the storm was
enough to get them and then they have
time to come after me I'm glad because I
had no defense policies really and so
that was it that's how I won fortnight
as a pacifist thank you for watching
[Music]